-♫ It´s the
"Wheel of Impressions ♫
-Now, how it works is
we´re gonna take turns
hitting this button right here,
which activates
the Impression Generator.
-[ Laughs ]
-It´ll land one one
random celebrity that
we can do impressions of.
-Right.
-And then, one random topic.
So whoever´s turn it is
has to do an impression
of that celebrity talking
about that topic.
Sara, since you´re my guest,
why don´t you go first?
[ Beeping ]
-Are you gonna give me that mic?
Kathleen Turner...
Kathleen Turner talking about
Slip N´ Slides.
So you have to talk about
-Okay.
-I have a microphone for you.
-You can look into
that camera there.
-Is this Kathleen Turner
20 years ago,
or Kathleen Turner today?
Today -- I´m gonna do today.
-If you close your eyes, this is
Kathleen Turner today...
-[ As Kathleen Turner ]
Oh, listen, Jimmy, believe me.
[ Laughter ]
I know all about Slip N´ Slides.
I walked that long, lonely
crocodile mile.
[ Laughter ]
And it always ends the same way.
You run, you slide, you hit
the bump,
and you take a dive.
[ Laughter ]
-Come on.
[ Ding ]
[ Band plays ]
Oh, my God.
Oh, my God!
She does Kathleen Turner
so good!
Okay, this is
my turn right here.
Let´s see what I get here.
[ Beeping ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
All right. Al Pacino...
Now, this is not saying
if it´s young Al Pacino
or old Al Pacino.
I´ll do both.
-Show-off.
-I´ll do young Al Pacino
talking to old Al Pacino
about Fidget Spinners.
All right, here we go.
-[ As young Al Pacino ] Oh, boy.
[ Laughter ]
You gotta see these
Fidget Spinners.
They spin, and all your problems
go away.
[ As old Al Pacino ] Oh, ah, it
is absolutely amazing,
spinning round and round
and round and round!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Ding ]
[ Band plays ]
[ Normal voice ] I don´t know
what I´m doing, I don´t know.
-I like how you almost threw
your neck out doing that.
You´re like, "Round and round!"
And it´s like, I got nervous!
-Young Al Pacino almost sounded
like Ray Ramano at one point.
Okay, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
All right, you´re up.
You can press the button.
[ Beeping ]
Okay, Holly Hunter talking about
a gas station.
I love Holly Hunter.
-[ As Holly Hunter ]
I love her, too.
This is great, Jimmy.
[ Laughter ]
This is so great.
I mean, this is so superior to
that service station
on Wilshire.
So, you got --
This is great, Jimmy.
This is so great.
I love this.
I love this so much.
Okay, you got all sorts
of snacks --
Skittles, Starburst,
sunflower seeds
if you´re trying to watch
your sugar.
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] That´s it.
[ Ding ]
[ Band plays ]
-Oh, my God!
You could do that all night!
That is so --
I can´t top that.
All right.
I´m gonna go anyway, though.
Here we go.
[ Beeping ]
Zak de la Rocha from
"Rage Against the Machine"...
-No, come on.
-McDonald´s drive thru.
[ Laughter ]
Questlove, you´re laughing
already.
[ Laughter ]
All right.
Could you give me a little
something?
Zak de la Rocha from
"Rage Against the Machine,"
I love them.
All right, here go.
[ Electric guitar plays ]
-[ As Zak de la Rocha ]
♫ Some of us who want nuggets ♫
♫ Are the same
that want sauces ♫
♫ French fry guy ♫
♫ Oh, my my ♫
♫ Get an apple pie ♫
♫ McDonald´s drive thru ♫
♫ We do wherever ♫
[ Ding ]
♫ Got the emoji
in my Happy Meal ♫
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That was very good.
-[ Normal voice ] No, no.
-No.
-There were nuggets,
there were emojis,
there were lots
of things going on.
Happy Meals, yeah.
-Sara, this is up to you.
This is the last one,
so please.
-No pressure, Jimmy.
Is this thing even on?
If not, it´s a trick!
-That´s fake.
That´s a rubber chicken.
-Yeah, this thing is not on.
Oh, now it is.
Very good.
[ Laughter ]
Very, very well done.
They responded to me.
-Yeah, they really did.
Yeah, you banged it on the desk.
Yeah, exactly.
Yeah, "Is this thing on?"
Now it´s broken, okay.
[ Beeping ]
[ Cheers ]
Drew Barrymore, basically
my sister-in-law,
we love Drew.
She´s family.
-[ As Drew Barrymore ]
I love her.
This is so -- I´m so --
Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you. Thank you so much.
Thank you.
I´m just gonna --
I´m so honored to be
in attendance today.
Okay, thank you so much.
Thank you.
-Are you talking about a
substitute teacher?
-I´m talking about
substitute teaching.
I´m so, so grateful to be here.
-But who is the teacher?
-Her name is Abby,
Abby Adamson.
And, oh, my gosh.
Abby, I love your name so much.
It´s like Aaaaah...
-Sarah Paulson!
[ Ding ]
You can´t beat that.
[ Band plays ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
You cannot beat that
with a bat, come on.
Sarah Paulson!
That is all the time we have for
"Wheel of Impressions!"